vous savez que il ya eu un certain
nombre de reproches dans la façon dont
vous avez interférer dans des activités
de presse je donne
plusieurs exemples
vous vous souvenez qu'à la suite de
cette une de libération vous concernant
vous avez supprimé l'ensemble de la
publicité de lvmh
avec 150000 euros de publicité en moins
pour le quotidien de la part du rau en
novembre deux ans c'était en septembre
2012 en novembre 2017 il y avait une
enquête du monde etc
toujours concernant les parts des spurs
et
[Musique]
le monde a été privée de publicité aussi
pour une hauteur estimée à 600 mille
euros
vous confirmez
que ça peut être quelqu'un
parce qu'il concerne libération puisque
vous avez vu la une en question est ce
que vous aviez le sur le sénateur
l'affût en question
ça vous avez paru tout à fait normal
d'avoir un titre aussi agressif contre
la première entreprise française pour
une motivation fausse parce que j'ai
jamais eu l'intention de devenir
résident fiscal belge se situe à
fantasmes encore une fois
ça vous aurez plus d'avoir ça et non
seulement il fallait accepter cette une
est fait
on faisait quasiment jamais de publicité
dans libération les lecteurs de
libération sont pas les clients du
groupe donc on a dit voilà on s'est
vengé en faisant plus de féliciter mme
on en faisait déjà quasiment pas
donc tout ça c'est
alors monsieur là effectivement j'ai
appelé le directeur de l'époque cette
nuit qui s'était dans les dix ans
libération maintenant
c'est incroyable de pouvoir traiter
des plus grosses entreprises françaises
et son actionnaire à son dirigeant de
cette façon c'est pas peut-être que vous
trouvez ça bien mais c'est rien je je je
je ne suis pas là pour vous dire si je
trouve ça bien ou pas bien et d'ailleurs
je vous avez absolument
là le droit plein et entier d'être
choqués d'être pas d'accord avec la
façon dont la presse peut traiter ou
votre personne ou vos activités mais le
sujet que l'on traite la
indépendamment des personnes c'est le
sujet des possibilités par la puissance
économique ou financière
d'utiliser cela pour interférer sur la
liberté de la presse parce que il ya
d'autres moyens si c'est ce que vous
avez est ce que vous avez d'autres
exemples je veux fini sur le monde je
vous dis c'est fou et sur libération de
toute façon faisait pas publicité alors
où est le problème du bien obligé moi je
vais vous répondre et je répète je
répète ce que vous avez d'autres formes
de solutionner teurs ce que vous êtes
d'autres exemples me montrer alors
ensuite il y a quelque chose qui a fait
un peu plus l'actualité c'est ces
derniers jours d'ailleurs
mais je pense que ça vous le
reconnaîtrez
il y a eu chaud
d'embauché on va dire en tous les cas de
missionné
par votre groupe
monsieur bernard ouardes square s'ils
n'y vont enquêter sur la vie privée et
sur la vie tout court de monsieur rufin
qui était en train de faire un film qui
va s'appeler merci pas trop au plus tard
je répète je ne juge pas telle ou telle
chose je suis factuelle que je me pose
la question la justice a
acté le fait qu'il y avait eu cela et a
proposé que moyennant le versement de 10
millions que vous avez accepté la farce
seraient closes
me confirmer cela pourquoi comment
qu'elle suit vous avez donné vous même
dans votre entreprise à
cette affaire
alors donc dans cette affaire d'abord
il faut savoir que c'est la justice qui
a proposé aux services juridiques
d'élever les marches cette formule de
cgg saisie et va de 2
d'accord le conventionnel vaussion
général est d'intérêt public on n'avait
pas demandé c'est le juge qui l'a
proposée aux quais et dans ce document
que vous pouvez le consulter nous avons
reconnu aucune culpabilité
donc je réfute toute culpabilité ce qui
a été approuvé par la justice française
dans ce dossier si vous n'essayez
d'insinuer qu'on est coupable en quoi
que ce soit dans cette affaire c'est aux
sénateurs je vous invite à lire la
décision de justice
je répète je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
dans un dialogue personnel avec vous je
10 ce qui est et je vous demande de
réagir justement je vous donne la
possibilité de donner des explications
et donc je vous avais accepté de donner
10 millions pour quelque chose où il n'y
a aucun sujet pour vous c'était comme ça
on l'a donc on a le le juge nous a
proposé cette transaction afin d'éviter
que nous soyons
pris dans cette affaire à laquelle on
n'avait rien à voir
notamment ont fait une responsabilité
quant à monsieur de faim sur femmes tout
le monde connaît c'est quelqu'un de très
brillant qui est d'extrême gauche et
pour lequel le groupe lvmh depuis
toujours
et est un épouvantail mais alors
pourquoi sommes nous un épouvantail
parce que nous sommes français parce
qu'on embauche en france parce qu'on
crée des ateliers en france et que c'est
un contre-exemple tellement flagrant
pour sa stratégie de communication qu'il
est obligé d'essayer de trouver des poux
dans la tête partout et si on a essayé
d'éviter que monsieur rifai lors d'une
assemblée générale où il avait prévu de
venir pour enfarinée tout le monde je
puisse entrer dans la salle
franchement non pas le problème non mais
je crois qu'on n'est pas sur le même le
sur la même longueur d'onde de réflexion
je répète ce qui nous intéresse ici
c'est de voir les possibles
interférences de
de puissance économique sur la liberté
d'expression la liberté de la presse des
faits que nous je parle les invente
passe pas moi qui étais les chercher ils
sont là et donc ce que je sais c'est
monsieur rufin dans cette affaire lui
n'accepte pas le jugement c'est-à-dire
qui le jeu et que vous vous l'acceptez
vous donnez 10 millions uniquement parce
que vous considérez que c'est une
c'est dire que maintenant si quelqu'un
vous attaque alors que les faits sont
infondées pour pas que d'affaires c'est
ça pour pas qu'on en parle et bien vous
donner des mises au jeu je pense pas que
c'est complètement comme ça mais la
presse a documenté les choses chacun se
fait une opinion mais j'aime moi j'ai eu
votre réponse et ça et c'est
qu'on peut continuer cette audition sur
des questions qui touchent un peu plus à
vous me confirmer que vous êtes encore
une participation dans l'opinion
[Musique]